e aí
g1
quem sabe aquele dia comum corriqueiro
eu fui para uma reunião nesta reunião
nós iríamos falar de educação chegando
lá eu conheci um cara fantástico só que
doido de pedra ele começou a falar
alguns assuntos que eu não fazia a menor
ideia do que se tratava
o bitcoin blockchain em redes
distribuídas
e sinceramente sabe o que aconteceu ao
fim dessa reunião eu continuei sem
entender porcaria nenhuma eu vontade de
ir embora e deixar essa história para lá
no entanto eu cheguei para ele e
perguntei cara explica um pouco sobre
isso melhor explica a sua empolgação
quando você fala por exemplo de redes
distribuídas
olá neste momento ele começou a explicar
rodrigo você sabe que você pode afetar
pagamentos realizar transações com uma
moeda chamada bitcoin eu já ouvi falar
ah e você sabe que isso só é possível
através de um pseudônimo satoshi
nakamoto é interessante por ser um
pseudônimo ele pode ser uma mulher um
homem ou várias pessoas ninguém sabe
quem é
e o mais interessante e aí eu fiquei
assustado porque sinceramente eu tenho
que confessar às vezes eu suspeito até
da nota que vai sair do caixa rápido
será que vai sair uma nota falsa agora
imagina que existem pessoas recebendo
com algo
o que ninguém sabe quem criou
e foi neste momento que começou a
construir toda aquela empolgação que
veio dele e passou a minha impactar
vamos pensar da seguinte forma
e durante a manhã eu olhei no espelho e
percebi que eu tinha que melhorar um
pouco visual
e sinceramente ficar menos feio resolvi
que eu ia em uma barbearia aquelas
barbearias todas as modernas que você
coloca uma toalhinha quente no rosto
pode até tomar uma cerveja escutar o
rock and roll
e quando termina o serviço termina de
cortar o cabelo fazer a barba eu tinha
algumas possibilidades para efetuar o
pagamento por exemplo eu podia pagar com
dinheiro cartão de débito ou crédito mas
também eu tinha eu tenho a possibilidade
de pagar com bitcoin e sabe porque isso
é possível porque existe uma estrutura
de dados que foram programada é um
sistema um software que funciona da
seguinte forma eu solicito uma transação
um pagamento neste momento existe uma
rede uma rede virtual distribuída onde
todas as pessoas podem fazer parte dessa
rede
e basta querer você pode fazer parte
você que tá aí no fundo também você eu
posso fazer parte dessa rede é claro que
a necessidade de um investimento em um
computador um gasto de energia e acesso
à internet no momento que eu solicito
uma transação acontece que é gerado um
bloco este bloco ele irá conter não só a
minha transação mas outras transações
ele é gerado ele é minerado de 10 em 10
minutos 24 horas por dia
e é interessante que minerar é resolver
um problema matemático de difícil
solução
ah mas de fácil verificação de fácil
validação como um cubo mágico e o
rodrigo tenho certeza que eu nunca vou
conseguir resolver esse problema isso é
um fato no entanto eu sei quando ele foi
resolvido isso é minerar um bloco a
partir do momento que esse bloco foi
minerado por um nó alguma das pessoas
que faz parte desta rede a minha
transação ela é adicionada a esse bloco
não só a minha como outras neste momento
este bloco também ele é distribuído
e quando ela é distribuído as outras
pessoas os outros nós tem a
possibilidade de agora fazer a validação
a verificação se esse bloco foi minerado
da forma correta e por exemplo se eu
tenho saldo em bitcoins para efetuar
esse pagamento
e é muito interessante que isso só é
possível porque uma rede block te
encomodo bitcoin ela é imutável
e transparente de fácil auditoria e
segura sabe o quê que isso gera
confiança isso também só é possível
porque existem alguns mecanismos como
rege protocolos de consenso e a própria
rede ser distribuída cada bloco que é
minerado ele passa a ter uma cópia em
cada computador ponto a ponto de todas
as pessoas que fazem parte da sua rede
não só o último bloco que foi minerado
todos os blocos que um dia foram
minerados isso impede a táxi ou melhor
deixa mais difícil que alguém derrube a
rede
e no entanto eu tenho que admitir
admitir isto é apenas uma explicação
superficial de uma tecnologia
maravilhosa que é o bloco tem
é o grande sentido o grande intuito aqui
hoje é mostrar aquela empolgação mostrar
porque uma tecnologia pode levar a esse
tipo de êxtase a esse tipo de empolgação
é isso para isso nós temos que entender
algo toda vez que nós realizamos uma
transação nós devemos ter confiança ou
alguém ou algo que diga você pode
confiar
quem sabe quem faz isso bem os bancos
mas existe um problema em 2008 eles não
fizeram isso também a crise de 2008 é
uma crise de confiança outro exemplo é
que a maioria das pessoas mais da metade
da população no mundo não tem sequer
acesso
e o sistema financeiro mais da metade da
população mundial não tem uma conta em
um banco isso demonstra muito isso fica
muito evidente o tamanho da desigualdade
que existe no nosso cotidiano no nosso
dia a dia interessante é perceber a
transformação de uma tecnologia
interessante é perceber que pela
primeira vez na história ou poucas vezes
na história nós temos a possibilidade de
não precisar de um intermediador que
centraliza decisão
e vamos imaginar a época do escambo nós
realisa vamos trocas por exemplo eu
quero trocar uma produção de milho o
trigo uma produção de banana e manga um
exemplo naquele momento um monarca
validado essa transação e na maioria das
vezes ele dizia qual o produto valia
mais entender essa transformação
entender que a revolução perpassa pelo
sistema financeiro é entender que nós
podemos nos apropriar de conceitos que
estão empregados nessa tecnologia isso
já está acontecendo
e o que isso é importante
é a importância de investigar é ter o
entendimento que nós somos frutos do
meio da mesma forma que nós
influenciamos o meio toda a tecnologia é
fruto de uma transformação
bom e como eu disse a famosa dialética
eu influencio e sou influenciado por
exemplo neste momento existe um projeto
muito lindo muito bacana de um jovem o
inovador social
a entender esses tipos de projeto me
remete ao que um dia um filme me disse a
grande diferença entre as pessoas que
percebem a oportunidade está no simples
ato de investigar ou não o cotidiano
vamos investigar o nosso dia o nosso dia
a dia vamos entender melhor o que está
acontecendo porque a partir daí nós
passamos a perceber que oliver um jovem
inovador social tem um projeto com o
objetivo de empoderar mulheres em
situação de vulnerabilidade mulheres que
não tem sequer a autonomia sobre as suas
riquezas sobre aquilo que elas produzem
através de uma rede blockit ele pretende
proporcionar isto a essas mulheres em
territórios que passam por exemplo por
crises humanitárias um território como
uma lower por exemplo
a entender essa transformação entender
essa revolução é saber que existe um
projeto na inglaterra de uma
universidade que tem o objetivo de
minimizar ou eliminar a intermediação
que centraliza as relações entre
professores e educandos como isso será
feito através de contratos inteligentes
smart contax autoexecutáveis o quê que
isso vai possibilitar esse possibilita
um ganho uma economia de recursos todos
nós entendemos ou a maioria que o
arcabouço operacional administrativo
requer muito investimento quando você
trabalha para minimizar isso minimizar o
intermediário você tem a possibilidade
que professores ganham um pouco mais e
educandos paguem um pouco menos
é de conhecimento entender essa
transformação é entender que eu rodrigo
um pequeno empreendedor posso pegar
todas as informações as movimentações
financeiras da minha empresa e colocar
dentro de uma rede blog share
e essa rede ela é imutável transparente
de faça auditoria ela é segura isso leva
a confiança quando nós temos confiança
nós temos melhor proteção a investir eu
terei melhores possibilidade de receber
o investimento na minha empresa e
proporcionar uma transformação local
a entender o que está acontecendo é
perceber que uma sociedade centralizada
ela é muito menos eficaz do que uma
sociedade distribuída sabe porque uma
sociedade distribuída trabalha com
conceitos como transparência
transparência é quando eu entendo que
cada nó da rede tem importância é quando
eu entendo que a minha performance vai
influenciar no outro eu quero deixar
evidente que eu estou fazendo de melhor
isso remete a auto responsabilidade
quando eu entendo que eu tenho que ter o
melhor desempenho eu vou fazer o meu
melhor eu vou fazer tudo o que eu posso
para deixar essa rede melhor
e isso leva respeito à diversidade vamos
pensar da seguinte forma sempre quando
nós somos contratados apenas pela nossa
ocupação profissão nós temos a tendência
a pensar de acordo com ela médicos
advogados engenheiros fazem isso agora
nenhum engenheiro nenhum médico pensa um
igual ao outro sabe por quê porque nós
somos frutos da nossa experiência nós
somos frutos de todo uma transformação
de toda a nossa vida é interessante
perceber que quando isso acontece nós
temos a possibilidade de autonomia e aí
eu passo a fazer aquilo que eu gosto eu
tenho prazer em fazer isso isso é
transformador por isso que nesse exato
momento eu posso afirmar que existem
pessoas que estão trabalhando ponto a
ponto nesse país pessoas a pessoas
entendendo que transparência auto
responsabilidade respeito
a idade autonomia é o futuro pessoas que
entendem que o bem comum é algo que tem
que ser cuidado e desenvolvido neste
momento eu queria fazer algo diferente
com vocês e queria fazer um pedido
queria que todos se levantassem por
favor
que podem se levantar com calma respirar
com calma porque até dá tempo de eu
respirar um pouquinho porque esse
relóginho aqui ele deixa a gente maluco
e agora com calma eu gostaria que vocês
se fechassem neste momento não eu
gostaria que vocês olhassem para todas
as pessoas que estão aqui hoje mas com
uma diferença eu gostaria que vocês
olhassem olho no olho para pessoa que
está na frente atrás do lado façam isso
vejam como é transformador dizem que
quando a gente olha dessa forma algo
pode acontecer
e agora eu vou pedir que você feche os
olhos
e começa a imaginar a trajetória de vida
de cada um de vocês ou a relembrar
e lembre-se de cada vitória cada derrota
cada experiência cada habilidade cada
qualidade que foi construída
desenvolvida ao longo da vida de cada um
respirem fundo pensa em dessa forma
só podem abrir os olhos
e agora eu quero que vocês imaginem as
possibilidades que existem aqui dentro
deste local as possibilidades que
existem dentro de cada pessoa que está
aqui hoje
eu imaginei isso dentro dessa cidade
dentro do nosso estado do nosso país de
todo o planeta isso é entender o
potencial de uma rede distribuída isso é
perceber que o caminho perpassa pela
valorização das pessoas entender que a
grande ideia não só lá do futuro mas já
do presente é perceber que o nosso
grande ativo que a nossa grande riqueza
são vocês as pessoas que estão aqui
neste planeta
e aí
oi eu gostaria de dizer que isso é só o
começo e que e fazer um convite vamos
fazer parte dessa transformação na
verdade vamos promover essa revolução
é muito obrigado a
e aí